sandy's is my taco truck this is how i
paid for all the obnoxious
selling on the weekends hey it's evan
carmichael and like grant cardone says
you don't need money to make money
okay you need people so let's help you
get people and make money with grant
cardone and my take on his top 10 rules
for success
[Music]
are you ready
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one extrovert yourself you should be
investing in yourself
some of you got more money in wells
fargo bank of america citibank
than you do in yourself
your self-improvement
is a no-brainer okay there's no money no
nothing nothing that no book i've ever
read that somebody can take away from me
it's impossible
give me one piece of data that's good
for me
give me one experience that's positive
for me no one can steal it you can't tax
it and it cannot be depreciated
see like i got no money on me right now
how many of you saw undercover
billionaire
yeah you should you should take a look
if those of you didn't see it you don't
need money to make money
okay you need people
as long as you as long as you're willing
to extrovert yourself into the community
and meet people hey how you do what's up
who are you
oh my god
like you don't even know how to do it
right you just need to be like hey
what's up everybody try this what's up
no no what's up
see people can be like what's wrong with
him
you should practice that this weekend
every time you go to the restroom or go
to the bar hey how you doing hey hey hey
how you doing oh hey
what's up
you know just say hi to people just get
used to extraverting yourself onto
people because people that you don't
know have everything that you want
and it's going to make you feel better
about you rule number two collect money
you got to go out and earn money period
well you don't really need to earn it
you just need to collect it you need to
get it
when you go around the money game you
got to remember this okay there is no
shortage of money on planet earth
there is no shortage of success on
planet earth there's more money than
there is people
there's more money than there are trees
there's more money than there are phones
and there's a lot of phones on this
planet there's more money than there is
tv shows like
you can't pick anything and by the way
anytime there's more of something then
there is money they just put up on money
money is printed you don't need to make
it you need to collect it
you need to collect it you need to earn
it you need to get it
so when you do your money target okay
the next thing you're going to connect
to is how do i get this money and that
will always be about the who
how to get money is about people it is
not about some idea it's not about i'm
gonna create an app i'm gonna
manufacture something it's not even
about i'ma solve a problem even though
you hear that all the time it's about
how
who
who
can help me solve my how you understand
who has my money who's got my money
who's got your money who's got your
million 10 million
who's got your
kids college tuition who's got your
christmas gifts who's got your halloween
uh costume whatever the case rule number
three protect yourself from inflation
the only asset class that will protect
you doing hyperinflation there's a
couple of them but there's only one that
cash flows gold certainly silver
yes
other other asset classes
that appreciate in value will get
accelerated
real estate however for the last couple
thousand years without exaggeration has
been the
the number one
the number one buy a long shot
asset class that will protect you and
your family against inflation this is
something you guys really need to worry
about uh the politicians are talking
about inflation being a problem for the
upper class look inflation
in fact
infects
like a virus
everyone okay inflation warren buffett
said inflation was like the invisible
tax
if you don't like taxes you're going to
hate inflation we have not had inflation
in this country in probably
the 80s since the 80s like so that's uh
you know
over half of my lifetime we have not had
hyperinflation particularly
hyperinflation where you're starting to
get escalated rates of food water prices
uh gasoline prices fuel prices diesel
prices
look at home prices just in miami i'm in
miami this morning
going to this event beautiful miami
these prices in the first 10 months of
2021 these prices went up 19
that is hyper inflation that means your
mortgage payment will go up almost 20
percent
that means your down payment will go up
uh if it's a
if it's a million dollar house or 400
000 house let's say it's a 400 000 house
and you had to put 40 000 down
uh just january last year that down
payment now is fifty thousand dollars
so you gotta get ready for this now how
do you protect yourself one you gotta be
aware of what inflation is number two
you gotta know if i have money that's
going down in value as assets go up it
takes more money
now this bag of money this bag of money
will not basically this was a hundred
thousand dollars in this bag and because
of the inflation in the last 12 months
this is now i just basically took this
much out of it you understand that's how
inflation works the bag was full
and now the bag is less full okay
because of inflation it's invisible but
it works in reverse meaning i just
simply need more of a bag i probably
need this bag and another 20 of this bag
to buy the same products and services
because of the printing of currency and
because of inflation it's not very
complicated and you don't need to figure
it out you just need to know number one
it's here number two i'm gonna do
something about it you need to do
something about it and the thing that
you can do about it is not a new thing
by the way folks this is not this is not
a bitcoin this is not bit clout this is
not nfts nfts ethereums this is nothing
this is not the the
medical metaverse this is nothing to
learn like this is simply i'm gonna find
an asset that cash flows
a real property that cash flows where i
protect my capital rule number four play
big bigger is not better
i remember a guy named phil told me this
he went bankrupt and then he says i just
want to remind you man bigger is not
better i had the bowling alley i had the
big house i had to die and i
and he's like bigger is not better man
and i believed it i bought it and so i
stayed small
um and
later i realized that
today i know bigger is definitely better
okay and and you just got to keep
getting bigger the problem with bigger
is you can't get out of the game
and you keep getting bigger and bigger
right you want to keep getting bigger
and bigger and it keeps bringing on you
can't get out of the game because then
you have obligations to other people now
there's a lot of employees but bigger is
more fun
and it comes with more problems but it
comes with more fun too
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five invest i will
never give the bank money until i invest
in my business
i'm never gonna save money at wells
fargo cash is trash folks how many were
taught you were brought up cash is king
it's garbage
it's pieces of paper if you saw the
stock if you saw the dollar as a stock
in the last 55 years it's going down
like this the graph is straight down
almost a 90 percent depreciation value
you would never invest in that stock but
what do you guys do work your ass off
trade time for money take the money and
save it so it gets depreciated what does
the bank do as soon as you give it to
them
they call me up hey mr cardone
can we lend you some of these people's
money their work hard-working people
they were working their asses off on the
weekends trading time for money and they
came and gave us the money it's amazing
these people do this over and over again
i'm like please send it over once you
and your business are doing well by the
way you'll know
it's not even a question if you're
calling me up like when should i start
investing grant
if you're still asking that question you
don't have enough money
it will be so obvious to you your
business is on banging it's banging 12
cylinders just banging man listings
coming in sales being made people
talking about you your freaking numbers
are going like this everything's like
straight up and vertical
then you should invest in something
where you cannot lose your money rule
number six have a dream the number one
thing is you got to make a decision
before you even take a step what is it
you want with wealth is it to just get
by
simply pay the bills you want to become
a millionaire a deca millionaire a
hectic millionaire a billionaire which
one you want to do i've done every one
of those
and i started with one thing the dream
what was the dream for me in the middle
in the very beginning was simply now i
just want to pay my bills and that was a
mistake because i was thinking too small
so
however high you set your goals and your
targets is going to determine where you
get so most importantly just set a
number is it a million 10 million 100
million a billion dollars rule number
seven improve yourself i'm greedy about
my own my own self-improvement
yeah i'm greedy and i am i am i am very
highly interested in my personal
self-improvement because i know that's
where it all starts i have to i have to
make me the most important thing in my
life
because other people can't get better if
i don't i would love to improve my
communication skills clubhouses like the
amount of eloquence the amount of people
there that are able to see other
people's viewpoints
has been fascinating to me
so number one i'd like to become a
better communicator
uh number two and i think i already am
just from being on clubhouse like
clubhouse has been an
incredible gift to me
yeah it's been fun it's been fun to be
in those rooms with you yeah and so i've
learned a lot about
how to talk how to listen
uh that i didn't know because of the
two-way communication you don't get that
from from facebook
and instagram yeah i don't get it from
dropping a video on youtube
number two is the collaboration i want
to collaborate with more people uh
number three third thing i want to do uh
you know i mean i need to work on my
relationships my personal relationships
uh
could be a better husband definitely a
better husband i've been go i've been
running really fast rule number eight
know your potential i don't push my kids
i'm pushing me
so if my kids can learn from me pushing
me
because i don't want anybody pushing me
you're never going to push me as hard as
i'll push me you know i had a manager
when i was 29 28 years old he set a
quota for me and i started laughing at
him and he's like what are you laughing
about i'm like dude how can you set my
quota
how can you set a quota for me dude you
you don't even know your potential much
less mine because i'm the one that knew
what i could be doing i'm sitting there
quietly as a salesperson i could come in
two hours early i got nothing to do i
was single
i was lonely i had nothing to do i could
have gotten work two hours early i could
have stayed four hours later how can
somebody that doesn't know what's going
on for me set my potential rule number
nine buy the best assets you're
compromising location because of price
buy the best assets you can buy folks
i've been doing this 30 years i've
bought what what are we at right now 10
000 units i'll be at 12 000 units by the
end of the year
i have bought and sold probably 15 000
apartments four plus billion dollars
worth i'm sharing with you from my heart
these are the mistakes i made i thought
too small
number two
i
compromised location over a little bit
of money
money is garbage okay the money i have
in my pocket
i mean let's face it it's not worth a
lot it buys goods and services it'll
trade at amazon you can't even go to
neiman marcus and drop the whole wad
anymore they won't take they won't take
two thousand dollars in cash they want
to put it on a credit card probably
their credit card okay so you got to
keep a lot of cash today
here's some more cash
what could happen to this cache somebody
could steal it it could get burned it
could get lost it could get misplaced
you can't misplace a great location a
great location where there's starbucks
and whole foods and maybe a chipotle and
there's traffic and there's jobs you can
never ever
pay too much
for a great location annual number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is have fun this is what's
most important and it's not this car
is this peace love and cash flow the
more cash flow you get the more peace
you're gonna have
i'm just telling you i i'd even tell you
that you might even have more love in
your life if you get more cash flow
the one thing about it one thing nobody
can say that i don't like i use
information i use experiences i leverage
everything
like i can i'm a co i consume
and i multiply
i don't just consume and and too many
people just consume and never use
so what do you mean by that they're just
they're consuming information but
they're never applying it yeah you you
you're either a consumer
a producer or an investor and and i'm
all three i consume it
i produce on it and then i invest in it
when i started twitter account i had no
followers when i started a facebook
account no followers
i was my first follower when i started
an instagram account no followers
um i didn't know how to post video i
didn't know how to take a selfie i
didn't know how to do any of this but i
did
have a commitment
to growing my finances
and if you want to grow your finances
attention is the gateway
you want to go to heaven who wants to go
to heaven
you got to die
i'm just telling you man you got to die
to go to the heaven
and most people don't want to die they
want to go to heaven but they don't want
to die most people want money but
they're not willing to get the attention
they're not willing to do what it takes
to get the attention
including spending money
and i would just tell you this if you
want to change your financial condition
the first thing you need to do is go out
and market in the marketplace so that
you can create a lead and not worry
about whether there's roi or not it's so
stupid that people are like what's the
roi
dude what's the roi if nobody knows you
okay what's the roi if i don't know your
name don't know your company don't know
what you do don't know your service
don't know your product don't know where
you're located what is the roi okay best
product does not win today the best
known product wins you think starbucks
sells the best coffee
please it's nasty
[Music]
okay
but it's close
and i know what i'm getting when i get
there mcdonald's they'll sell the best
hamburger
close and available you need to think
way bigger than you're thinking i
started in the apartment game uh 25
years ago in san diego california my
first deal first deal i ever bought was
one unit this little yellow house that i
paid 78 thousand dollars for by the way
all this landscaping that's one of the
things i'm known for i'm like i'm
putting trees up there because that's
going to give me some extra rent it
didn't by the way my next deal was 38
units
okay it was easier buying 38 units than
it was one the only difference was to
think
i had to think different
got to make a few more phone calls but
the play is bigger right the reason
people the reason so many real estate
people are like marginal people no
offense
raise your hand if you're marginal
they left on dates raise your hand if
you're a liar
look man look i'm marginal
to compared to my potential
the fact that there's people in this
room that don't know me i've written
seven books 13 best-selling business
programs
i have i'm probably the top one or two
maybe three social media people in the
world seven million people on facebook
but seven million people on facebook is
nothing compared to seven billion people
in the world problems are opportunities
the bigger the problems if you could
look for the giant problems on this
planet and quit complaining about them
right and quit blaming somebody about
them and say man what if i took
responsibility for that problem
because there is money in solving
problems
you solve a problem
you'll end up with money
and the bigger the problem you solve
the bigger the problem you solve the
more money you end up with first 35 40
years of my life i was being held back
by what i knew what i thought was the
truth it wasn't the truth
these people and companies that are
buying private jets
that are hooking up with whoever they
want when they want that are spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars on
connections and speed and access
dude look what are they doing man what
are they doing okay
they're doing something different than
you and i were taught to do the school
systems don't teach you this your mama
didn't teach you this your daddy didn't
teach you this
your family doesn't know this right so
you got to go outside your circle of
influence
and look around
12 14 million
6
[Music]
a little guy a little guy right here got
the big jet on the tarmac
how's a little guy like me end up making
it all the way up the food chain
because i studied those guys
and you can do the same thing if you
study hard enough the right people
not those guys those are the pilots okay
see they work for 150 grand a year i
think they're there they're cutting a
big fat hog and they ask oh i make 175
000 but they stop learning what the
owner knows
okay study man study paid the price for
the information and then pay
for the price of access to the people
and learn from them if i could go back
to my 20 year old self what i would tell
my 20 year old self is
one thing
get your money right son
worry about the money and i know a lot
of people think that this is not the
thing people should be focused on
however
on this planet if you don't get your
money right you're going to be worried
all the debt all the time you can't take
care of your parents you can't take care
of yourself you can't take care of your
rent you can't live in a nice place you
can't take care of your car get your
money right okay
what should you be spending your money
on why do wealthy people use money not
spend money why do wealthy people buy
businesses they don't buy homes why do
wealthy people use debt to grow their
business they don't use debt to consume
products and services why do wealthy
people not invest in 401ks and seps and
retirement accounts they don't even
worry about that they worry about
getting their money so freaking right
that they can go wherever they want day
or night is saying hey man if you got a
million dollars you're basically just a
freaking deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income
and you were
how old are you you're 27 years old i'm
gonna do this at 47 i'm gonna do it at
uh at at 65.
27 you don't have any more income how
long will that money last
at 4 000 a month
you got 25 years
where can you live
on 4 000 a month you'd have to live on 4
000 a month for 25 years you will be 52
years old my friend
and dead broke
number one thing you got to do is this
you got to change the target and you
need to look at the target daily the
target you have the wrong target right
now if you're struggling you have the
wrong target
when you change the target everything
changes now and and i started with zero
just so you guys know i didn't have
anything okay so look it's simple target
what's your new target freedom
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it
your first target should be 10 million
and nothing short of that number one the
target number two you need to get your
income to a place this is a fascinating
concept right here
okay if you can do this i guarantee
you'll be rich
you need to get your income not to what
pays your bills but to where you can
save 40
of your gross income
is saved
all right so now now when you do this
math you're like dude how much money do
i actually need let's kick this up to 20
grand at 20 grand what happens you're
saving eight
storage
you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget
you make thirty thousand
twelve is going to storage
12 is going to the ir and the s
and that leaves you with 6. so now you
can start seeing do you got to be
somewhere north of 300 grand a year this
is what they don't teach you at harvard
you've got to be somewhere north to 360
a year before you even have money to
live on unless you're just
you know you're direct
you're just an irresponsible human being
that that's
you know not putting storing money away
for the future
okay now you're saving 12 grand a month
that's 144 000 in one year in 10 years
that's 1.4 million dollars in 10 years
you're a millionaire stored
you guys need to be heavily money
motivated from a survival standpoint
okay number three thing you're gonna do
you're gonna go broke right here
and invest
the storage
storage has to get invested
the golden goose is only good if she
lays eggs
otherwise you can kill her eat her for a
chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies right so your goal right here is
to invest
to invest the storage money
and continue to do that until this money
over here the passive money
is equal
to
your income
[Music]
right so what would i do i'd go out i'm
gonna make 30 grand i'm gonna store 12
i'm gonna pay the irs i'm gonna live on
six warren buffett says don't lose money
number one number two don't lose money
i would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what peter thiel was
saying a single digit millionaire cannot
even provide themselves with their own
personal
defense in america
okay hulk hogan all that money hulk
hogan made he blew it all
he blew it all probably buying hair
pieces
okay he blew it all he blew it all ended
up with a little money thought he was oh
man i got a little money until he had
that freaking lawsuit and then he can't
even defend himself
so it happens to a lot of people how
many how many of you know a family
member lost their job
okay how many of you have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to to rehab for
30 days and it cost 40 grand
that happens how many of you know
somebody got cancer
okay how many know somebody in a car
accident cost three or four hundred
grand
[ __ ] happens
okay the problem is not that [ __ ]
happens it happens and people aren't
ready for it oh god i can't believe this
happened to me oh really
goddamn you've been around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
[Laughter]
you live on a planet with water
i'm just saying you might want to get a
swimming lesson
it's a wet planet i love baseball but
but but you don't have to love baseball
to be inspired by greatness watch this
watch this what's this let's just
oh my god
so beautiful look at this
is that amazing wow
greatness man that's greatness i got
that guy he you know when you when i
watch that i'm like i wonder how many
times he's run jumped
taken flying pitch i mean thousands and
thousands and thousands of times to get
to have that moment right there so by
the way that's that's in everybody here
okay so if you ever see a great ball
play uh whether it's football or hockey
or ballet or dancing and you're inspired
it's because it's it's hitting that part
of you that's like you have that in you
you've got
everywhere you go
you need to you need to confront every
time you hit up against oh the room's
249
the the mill is 25 bucks uh starbucks is
six dollars the airline flight costs
600. every time you like oh
okay you need to understand that you're
being reminded you don't have enough
money
it has nothing to do with the price
but but watch how much people
disassociate
oh american airlines is charging too
much for that ticket
that has nothing to do with it you don't
you don't make enough money
okay so i had a guy i was in oakland
california i was flying back and i said
uh hey anybody want to fly home with me
and the guy's like i want to fly home
with you i'll do it i said good i'll be
48 000 for fuel oh oh i don't want to do
it
no you can't do it because you don't
have the money
fuel is not the problem he didn't he
doesn't make enough money so just start
flipping things so like now when i see
wagyu remember that wago we ate in vegas
it was like 115 for a strip that big
never do it again by the way
but the fact that i complained about it
only means
i don't make enough money
[Music]
and if the wago's too much money
if the 115 for a little strip of wagyu
is too much money
what does that say about what i'm
selling my products for
not charging them up can't get enough i
have this idea so it's really to me it's
we go to paris man and we go to the
chanel store and there's people in line
in line out the front door at the chanel
store i'm like oh my god great
experience for me
how much money is on this planet go to
monaco see the yachts 200 million 240
300 million dollars 300 millions they
cost 30 million a year to take care of
them
great experience
flying private been a great experience
for me i was 50 52 years old and i had a
problem i was depressed
i wasn't satisfied i was hungry but
didn't know what to do i had businesses
i had money i had a whole bunch of stuff
but i'm like dude what am i doing now
i'm bickering with elena
we had our kids
we had the first two kids and we're like
okay we got a kid i'm being a parent now
okay i'm being a married guy right i'm
being a businessman and i'm unhappy and
then i start asking people what's wrong
man what's wrong what's wrong with me
man something wrong with me something
wrong with me oh yeah and as soon as you
say there's something wrong with me [ __ ]
everybody's got an opinion
oh yeah man man you got a disease man
you got a problem you got issues man you
work too much you're a work addict
you you you you're insecure your daddy
died your daddy died and left a hole in
you
left a hole in me i can't go on a
vacation
i want to do something man
doing less has never solved my problems
[Music]
doing less moderation has never solved a
problem for me
the problem that i've had in my life
okay was not my marriage
there's not okay i'm not a bad parent
i wasn't helping enough people
[Applause]
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling you should
be helping more people if you guys look
around man it would appear to me that 99
of the people that you run into today
are having some kind of financial
problem
oh 76 percent of americans live paycheck
to paycheck i know people that don't
live paycheck to paycheck that worry
about money every second of every day
when my dad died
i didn't know anything about the one
percent but i knew i wanted to get that
club i'm like i have to get above
whatever this middle-class thing is
because there's no safety here it's
constant fear
i've only wanted money for one reason to
be out of fear so i could help out so i
could give to charities so i could help
my brother so i didn't have to worry
about how much the fuel cost or do i run
an ad budget or not man you guys got to
get out of the fear man that's the whole
purpose okay the fear by the way is not
a conspiracy that [ __ ] is real everybody
like oh fear ain't real yeah well uh-huh
it's easy for you to say you ain't got
any this second
okay because it ain't scary to write a
damn quote or to post something on
instagram that [ __ ] ain't scary what's
scary is going to take a loan for 60
million dollars
see if you ain't got a little bit of
scare
okay saying no to a customer hey man
you're wrong okay my daughter told me
the other day customers are always right
papa no they're not no they're not and
most people don't even know how to tell
a customer they're wrong i lost my dad
when i was 10 i lost my brother when i
was 20. i lost you know i i gave up my
career and maybe i'm gonna be a baseball
player to drugs i've lost five or six
jobs now and i'm a loser i'm a total
loser but i do have this little this
little light inside of me that says i'm
special i have this little thing inside
of me and says hey you you are special
you know you have something
but it was just covered up in all this
stuff
and all these problems and the in the
drugs and the bad friends and the bad
choices so my mom finally says enough is
enough don't come back here anymore i'm
done i could tell it was hard for her
i'm in a treatment center in the next 24
hours
i go to this treatment center i'm there
30 days for the first 30 days in seven
eight nine years
i don't use drugs
wow i i don't have to use drugs finally
that thing where i said i was quitting
10 times a day i was quitting 10 times a
day for the first time in my life i was
able to quit successfully
i'm leaving the treatment center when
the insurance ran out because that's how
those work
when the money runs out they boot you to
the curb i'm terrified scared to go back
to society i don't have any friends that
aren't using drugs my girlfriend was
using drugs everybody around me
everybody i knew use drugs
and i'm going back to a job where even
at the job i had they use drugs
and i'm like i'm going back to an
environment i have to cut off all my
friends
not really friends i got to cut off all
the enemies right and and i got to start
over and before i leave the counselor
grabs me and the counselor says to me
look dude i'll see you back here
probably you know if you don't die i'll
see you back here and i'm like what are
you talking about dude i'm not coming
back here and he's like oh no you're
coming back
and then he gives me the lecture
he's like you'll never make it
see when you go to a treatment center
you tell them everything about your life
like all your secrets all your your your
your
your inhibitions
and and your you know the things you
want to do in your life right and so
i'm telling them in this thing
everything i've done everything i've
done wrong i share my whole life but i
also share with them what i want to do
my inspiration in life i'm going to
write books i'm gonna speak to audiences
i'm gonna help people i'm gonna tell
people this story about drugs and how
damaging they are
and i'm gonna be somebody i tell them
and they're like no no no no
you're a drug addict
and all you're ever gonna be is what the
counselor tells you all you're ever
going to be is a drug addict you need to
give up all the ideas of writing books
speaking to audiences
being rich i always wanted to be rich i
wanted financially to be rich my whole
life i wanted to be my dad i wanted to
be the guy that could take care of his
family he said you need to give up all
those ideas and settle for one thing
not using drugs i just got
awarded awarded this deal 92.5 million
dollars 31 acres of land my buddy evan
carmichael talks about dream believe
yeah but dream what and believe what
believe you pay your bills or believe
you can one day write a check for 60
million bucks what do you believe what
are you gonna dream of
like literally i think people's dreams
are one of the things holding them back
because they don't know how to dream i
don't know how big to dream this is
doable for any person i don't care who
you are anybody could do this deal
anybody could do that deal i know the
guys that own private jets they're no
smarter than anybody else
they're not smarter they don't work
probably don't even work any harder
[Music]
but they did they did think bigger
and they get in the in and you can't you
can't catch whales
in it in a in a bowl goldfish bowl money
follows attention money follows
attention
how much attention can you guys get
okay most of you can't get attention
because your mom and daddy said
don't get too much attention
don't get too much attention be seen
and not heard fly under the radar
because if you get too much attention
they're going to shoot you down
right how many heard this before fly
under the radar man stay low man don't
let anybody see you making moves don't
make moves man don't make moves
and then everybody wonders why can't i
get above
because you don't get attention
strangers have everything you want
everything you want a stranger has it
it will be strangers that will grow your
business
it will be strangers that put your kids
through schools it will be strangers
that make your dreams a reality
strangers have everything you want but
you were taught not to talk to them we
can't afford that how many have told
your kids about that before we can't do
that bike we can't buy the bike
right
you told your kids that because you were
told that right we don't tell our kids
that how many of you are told these kids
be careful
that's why you guys think so much
you got you got dave ramsey on tv saying
total freedom
comes from
not having debt
okay you got you you flip channels and
you go to susie you can't afford that
okay i'm going to tell you do you can
afford anything
no no
hey that's not your problem okay i got
four four i probably got 500 million
dollars worth of debt today
500 million i wish it was 5 billion i
had to get over drugs
went to treatment center spent 28 days
in a treatment center when i was 25 my
mom my brother my sister all gave up on
me
like they're like enough that's how bad
a trouble i was and i was using i was
using drugs every 45 minutes
i wasn't using drug once or twice a day
i was using once or twice an hour
whatever you're not going to do in the
business meeting you probably shouldn't
be doing period
so i had to clean up i had to clean up
my deal man
28 days i got 28 days first 28 days of
my life in seven years that i didn't use
drugs i was like [ __ ] man what am i
gonna do now my fear wasn't using drugs
again my fear was what am i gonna do
with all my time
so when you see me run right now i'm
running from one thing to the next thing
trying to stay
busy as long as i stay busy i don't get
in trouble by the way i'm the guy that
couldn't pay his rent
275 a month in rent and i couldn't pay
it most of the time 45 i recommitted to
my education but this time i started
studying not things that were in books
but people that it actually created
wealth
not people that had made money but
people that had created wealth
this is completely different i was no
longer studying accounting and economics
i was studying wealthy people and only
wealthy people i'm not talking about the
doctor that was a neighbor
that makes a million dollars a year and
he's working 18 hours a day and he hates
his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with ben i'm
talking about the yacht people i'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation i'm talking about the car
dealer that had
28 car dealerships or 82 car dealerships
that has indisposable money i'm talking
about the walton money we're talking
about the waltons last week increased
their net worth by 11 billion dollars
and they haven't worked for 30 years
that's the kind of wealth i started
studying i started reading barons in the
wall street journal and i quickly
realized something
that the wealthy people
had financial freedom and no one else
did okay a very small percentage of
people lots of people have money my
uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money wouldn't spend
it acted like a miser buried money in
the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong and
this is the number one thing i want you
to get out of tonight
the information you have is wrong
the wealthy talk differently than the
middle class i watched my mom and my dad
i started comparing the wealthy people
to what my dad did my dad worked every
day every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard
they saved money they cut their own
grass okay we ate all our food we turned
the lights off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow on trees a penny
saved is a penny earned eat all your
food people are starving okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that creates insecurity
and it's incorrect if you want things to
change they can change
and they're not going to change just
because you pray
just because you wish just because you
hope and they won't change just because
your family wants it to change it did
not change until until i started getting
information
and
if you're taking notes today it didn't
start changing until i started getting
rid of information one of the most
important things that happened to me in
my life was to get rid
of information
a man told me once he's like hey look
man if things aren't going well somebody
or something is causing it not to go
well how many agree with that statement
okay things aren't going well something
or someone is causing
things not to go well different game
today folks different game man
everything's changing remember when you
waited for a taxi cab
remember that when was that
how many people on this planet
complained about having to wait on a
dirty cab
[Music]
millions and millions and millions of
people said oh my gosh hey man let's
just send it to him if you can close the
distance between an idea and money
okay
you'll get rich when i was a kid when i
was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
i was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled everything in this
environment
and he left early for work he came home
late
took care of his family and you knew he
never gave anybody a lecture about what
to do
he he just lit he was a good example
and um
and he had the money and he made the
money
[Music]
we were middle cla middle-class family
so we were like
little red brick house
white brick actually white brick house
about 1400 square feet seven people
lived in it
and my dad i could tell my dad was
trying to get somewhere he was trying to
move us up
he was trying and he wasn't trying to
brag
he was trying to take care of
and so i was watching that right and i
watched where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed
and i started associating that the money
maker makes the rules
this is what elena was talking about you
know there's around the money i make the
rules around the money around other
things elena makes the rules so
you got to know what you're good at what
your job is and what your role is my dad
and my mom knew their roles
the problem with that is when my dad
died suddenly at 52 years old my mom was
left
to do something she didn't she didn't
have she was not skilled up to do
and and i was 10 and i wasn't i didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death insurance better
better it's really called death
insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that and
my mom
didn't know how long that money would
last so immediately after my dad died
when my mom should have been in grief
she she went immediately into massive
fear and i could see it i could sense it
as a 10 year old my mom was in fear
every day
clipping coupons saving money
you know turn the lights off
eat all your food it was constant
messages
go across town to get gas
like everything can't buy strawberries
today
you know they'll be they'll be 20 cents
cheaper tomorrow
everything was about
fear
and so i
i couldn't do anything about it or
didn't think i could do anything about
it
and i just kept telling myself one day
one day i'm gonna be in a position to
change this
and i think that really drives me today
to like
take care of
people not be in that situation again my
buddy dummy right here
never moves
you can come hit on him as much as you
want slapping
reminds me of the first
like
25 years of my life
this would be right here
i just take it never moved
but i look good
wouldn't read
just a damn dummy there's this old thing
about people read 60 books i could take
one book and read it 60 times if it's a
good book i don't abandon that book for
a second book i'm like i'm gonna dig in
now
the the free the shipping on the books i
get an idea for a real estate book
oh i should do a real estate book
everybody's asking me every day do a
real estate book do a real estate book
oh i'm going to write a book we write a
book on real estate
do i sell the book or do i give the book
away for free
why don't we do both
let's see who wants to give me 25 bucks
in shipping and let's see who wants to
get it for free and shipping
we did almost 80 000 books in six weeks
that's the most books i've ever done
right the whole process took 30 days
idea
monetized we made money on the book
before i had the book in print i got an
idea right here everybody in the room's
got ideas everybody great
the problem is they don't they don't get
the money fast enough the shorter the
runway between the id and money the more
successful the business is going to be
my first book had over
600
grammatical errors
run on sentences
prepositions in the wrong place
exclamation marks colons where there
should have been semi-colons i had
people like dude you got you this book's
got misspellings on every page i'm like
it's a best-selling book
you know the guy that told me that never
read never never wrote a book
he's so busy reading books and not doing
anything
by the way how many books have you not
written you don't have more money folks
because now it's not it's not because
you don't work it's not because you're
not a good person it's not because you
overspend it's not because you've got
too much debt it's not because you don't
bust your ass
it's because your money doesn't bust its
ass
your money is lazy if your money
was employees you would fire your money
here's the rules okay number one the the
money the extra money should go into
something that gives you money you want
your money to have babies the golden
goose is no long no longer good if she
doesn't have
eggs
the only thing that makes the golden
goose valuable is the fact that the
golden goose lays legs lays eggs so if
you just study the wealthiest families
in the world not just in america in the
world over long periods of time
look at the queen the queen of england
this much property and one of the
richest families in the world why they
get cash flow every month
from india
from england from ireland from all over
the world why why are the princes in
saudi arabia so wealthy because they
have constant inflow
of money coming from the land that
produces the oil the oil comes out of
the land and produces cash flow the
railroads the railroads back in the day
what did they do they got all this land
together and then they rented that land
out to everybody around it why do all
the teachers credit unions take all the
money from all the teachers around
america and then they start investing in
real estate that produces cash flow so
they can distribute back to their
members
i'm always going to come back to this
one story look real assets that produce
real cash flow every month
when it pays you every month and you're
getting reminded every month i got a
check i got a little hundred dollar
check i got a 200 check this month i got
a 13 000 check today from one of my
properties
every month i get a check for 13 grand
from that property
it's 150 dollars a year it didn't start
like that it used to be like thirteen
hundred bucks thirteen hundred then it
was twenty six then it was five thousand
next thing you know it's 13 grand that's
one property pays me every month
property just sits there okay it just
sits there it might not even change in
value it just sits there and produces
cash flow anything that produces cash
flow will be worth more money tomorrow
that's why netflix is valuable why
because people pay a lot of cash into
netflix and even if netflix loses money
today some company will find netflix
desirable for one reason
cash flow is king will you start getting
all oh god damn dude
look
this is stupid
these cars
that you're seeing people buy
i think 50 cent got six of them for
christmas or something
i got my wife a culinard and i got
myself this this is ridiculous you don't
need to go out and buy these cars okay
this is
without a doubt complete waste of money
and unlike unlike some of the people
that are out buying because there's a
lot of young kids right now thinking oh
i'm gonna go buy a lambo i'm gonna get a
ferrari i'm gonna go buy me a rose i
watched a 24 year old kid buy a rolls
royce i'm like man i don't even look
good on you even if you can't afford it
what you see right here is completely
ridiculous but years 35 years of hard
work not just hard work but making good
decisions and putting the money away
putting the money away and not doing
this kind of stuff
put all this stuff off don't do this
right now okay pay the price right now
work hard get great at your job get
great at whatever you do so good that
people are like man you're the best well
who are you what are you on they start
asking questions about wow what makes
you so unique
then you're gonna start getting paid
more there's no way on this planet that
if people don't if people start talking
about how exceptional you are you will
get paid more at some point
when you do take that money and invest
it in something where you can't lose it
where it pays you every month and one
day in the future it'll be worth more
than it is today
do that for years it might take 10 years
15 years 20 years
i'm just starting to enjoy my life
a lot of hard work man you can't stay
connected to the y i don't mean why am i
doing this but you got to dig down the
why behind the why behind the why right
why do i want to lose weight why do i
want to be in better shape why
[Music]
because because it because it's going to
make me healthy but why do you want to
be healthy why did i start investing in
real estate
and by the way why did i start making
more money so i could have more money to
invest in real estate why do you want to
make more money so you can have more
money to invest in real estate why oh
because i want to spend more time with
my kids man because i want to be on a
vacation with my kids and not worry
about what we're doing i want to be able
to go to sleep or go travel or do
whatever i want and i got money coming
in and i want to be able to take care of
my parents and my church and my charity
i want to take care of stuff after i die
that's why i invest in real estate no
more drinking no more drugging no more
weekends until i get my money right just
like job sales second thing i would do
is this i would invest
my extra time
not my money my extra time i would
invest learning about real estate
without a doubt
if i would have been doing this at 20
years old i'd be worth over a billion
dollars today
all i had to do was focus different what
i did was i got caught up in this first
job
and i started thinking about how good i
was doing
one day looked up i was 35 years old 33
years old actually and my uncle says you
need to start paying attention
to your money
to money working he said it to me one
time man one piece of advice i got from
my uncle he's like you need to start
paying attention you need to get your
money work and i'm like okay thanks you
need to hate your life you guys don't
need to like i'm good i'm all happy i'm
good i'm i'm living the dream you need
to get so disgusted i told you this
eight years ago get so disgusted with
your life
get so freaking like you hate your life
so much
that that the thing that that where you
go every day is a solution to getting
the life you want people keep asking me
dude how do you keep your freaking mojo
going like
it it's like it's like you got more
energy i said well it's a beautiful
having a beautiful wife thank you
handsome women women women let's just
call us
women are the super
uh motivators of the universe this is my
muse right here oh
god in addition to the muse though
okay okay it's a new me this year folks
really in addition to the muse you guys
got to have a pull
you need to have a pull you're like man
why how do you stay how do you guys stay
so motivated it's the pull it's not the
push jordan wins a ring and he's like
okay now what everybody else is out you
know drinking champagne but this the
true champions are like what's the next
thing what's the next move what do we do
next like they need the next thing to
keep them going
but when am i ever gonna be satisfied
you need a pool you're never gonna be
satisfied
and if you are by the way by the way if
you are satisfied you quit the speed
at which
you
commit determines your velocity
how fast i can commit to something will
determine how fast i can move into that
thing and how much power i have okay the
speed at which you commit the longer you
take to commit to something
the less impact it's going to have on
your community on yourself on your life
on your money your finances i don't care
if it's rehabbing your kitchen
buying a house
and making an investment in real estate
the speed at which you can commit dude i
want to collaborate with people i don't
want to compete anymore i'm done with
the competition [ __ ] so when you hear
when you hear about such things i think
of me you everybody that teaches them
you hear all that early sales stuff for
me
i was in such a competition mode
it was i was competing with everybody i
thought it was me against everybody
and really it's just been in the last
since we did that first growth
conference
and we had other people on stage and i
didn't do like i didn't do any of the
speaking yeah
i was just introducing people doing
interviews and walking uh doing doing q
and a's
father's side even the second even the
second one even russell brunson says
dude why would you why are you giving up
all your stage time to other people
because i want to collaborate yeah
and and but then we figured that the
other people don't really know how to do
it yet like
they're like hey follow my instagram i'm
like that's not a collaboration we don't
care about your instagram when i took
spent six million dollars trying to get
30 000 people in a row yeah
right now we care about where is
everybody going for the next through
next year and 2020. your surroundings
have to change
okay the people your network your
scenery
you will not change your life until you
change the people in your life my daddy
abandoned me
my sister's not gonna like hearing that
because she's like oh my god he was good
to you he died
he left me too soon
period
call it whatever you want okay he left
me too soon
he left my brother too soon okay me and
my brother without a dad man tremendous
amount of energy
[Music]
same kind of like like just imagine me
as a 10 year old in louisiana
with a weapon
[Applause]
[Music]
right
i'm 10 years old we had a 22 rifle i'm
out shooting everything that moves
cars
anything anything and everything i'm
wild man i'm wild i got all this energy
and i don't have a dad and i'm angry
i told my mom when i was 16 years old
one day one day i'm gonna be successful
one day
one day i'm gonna be successful and one
day i'm gonna help a lot of people
and i said that to her because i wanted
somebody to help me
see i've always loved helping people
always
i am most happy when i'm helping someone
else
nothing to do with money
if i can help somebody
not give them something but if i can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
if i can help somebody know how to do
that
i know i contributed to their life
sabrina can't set the right goals right
now everybody agree with that sabrina
can't she can't pick up 200 pounds
you understand she could fly on a jet
one of my kids has never been on a
commercial airline she's like papa will
i ever get to fly a commercial
i hope not
i hope you never have to go through that
it's
wrong
i did three million miles so you don't
have to
peanuts i didn't want
and i was doing that on thanksgiving
holidays to go to canada where they were
they were still transacting business
super bowls i've missed ball games i've
missed my buddies were traveling seeing
the world and i didn't have any of those
experiences
it's been 30 years
30 years it's probably going to be 30
years for you too it's going to be 30
years of it are you willing to pay the
price if anybody thinks
you're going to be successful without
paying that price
you're wrong earn money learn how to
store the money and learn how to use it
because if you can't do this if you
can't flow the money back out if you're
sitting on a grand right now or two
grand or five grand
make it official that you're broke
do not try to save five grand
it's no money
just
make it official
get rid of it
and be broke
because you're broke already and maybe
you'll hustle now like you need to
replace your reserves that's why when i
earn some money i store it okay if if if
i store 30 million dollars i know i'm
getting rid of it twice a year i dump
everything i have entire every penny i
have does not go into some emergency
account it goes into an asset that will
make
babies or make me known
and you guys can do this
everybody in the room can do this okay
if i can do this you guys can do this
you need a network a team of people
around you that can hold you accountable
you will go nowhere by yourself not even
jesus went by himself
nobody goes by themselves nobody
all right you have more potential you
know if that's the answer to that get
there be vip while you're there too by
the way
vip
have a vip experience
if you can't vip yourself why do you
think somebody else is going to treat
you like a vip i don't know where i am
most the time i don't know what day it
is i don't know what time it is i just
know hey i got this moment man right
here let's make the most of this moment
i don't know if i live once or twice
okay i know this i need to take
advantage of what i have right now and i
can't do that by myself i don't want to
be by myself we don't want to just be
the four of us
i don't want to just be me elena sabrina
and scarlet i want to i want i want a
nation i don't want a tribe
i don't want to tribe i want friends all
over the world i want sabrina and
scarlett when they grow up and they go
to to switzerland they have friends in
switzerland
okay if the world falls apart we have
friends in oklahoma or in central
or maybe i gotta go to south america for
a while maybe i gotta go hang out
okay i will not fulfill my mission my
mission is to help people
i will be known for the people i helped
not the money i made nobody's gonna
remember nobody's gonna say 50 years
from now 100 years from now oh grant
cardone had a great jet nobody nobody
will ever mention that
my books might live on okay my audio
will guarantee you my audio will live
long after i'm dead
but your memories with me you using our
technologies okay
will live on forever
you live on through other people walt
disney did it
he lives on today man okay
build a legacy folks build a legacy put
yourself out there okay 10x your lives
10x the lives of the people around you
getting ready to do a real estate
conference for a thousand experienced
and mature real estate investors if you
knew what i was going to share with them
the one biggest most important number in
all of real estate investing there's one
thing if you read my book you know what
it is i'm going to share it with them
today and it's going to blow them top
off their heads there's some people in
the room that are retired from apartment
investing and they're going i guarantee
you when i'm done today
they're gonna be like
honey
what was rethinking getting out of this
game we gotta get back in it we did it
wrong cause we did it small
hey if you're not investing in
apartments seriously if you're not
invested in apartments if you don't know
the game how to learn the game learn the
game figure the game out i promise you
with every fiber of my being i believe
that apartment investing will prove to
be over the next 25 years the single
best investment up here
that you can make that you can possibly
make your life is not the way it should
be then you should hate yourself right
now i don't blame you you should the
best way but dude i i hated my [ __ ]
before i loved my
i hated myself so bad i couldn't look in
the mirror
jared told me the other day he's like
you don't have a mirror in your bathroom
i can bring you in there right now
there's no mirror in there check this
out
i said dude i don't need a mirror i
remember you know what that bathroom i
remember having an apartment where i
couldn't put a mirror on the wall broke
it
i broke the mirror look at that right
there there ain't no mirror i told the
chair yesterday i said dude i don't have
a mirror i said i don't care i don't
need to look at myself i remember when i
looked at myself and i hated myself
broke the mirror out of my bathroom
because i couldn't look at my face
because the mirror reminded me every
time i had a mirror i was putting
something on it to put it in my face
i hated myself man hated myself didn't
have any money
had all this potential
overdosing daily you guys want a man you
want to change you got a bunch of
potential tell you tell yourself the
truth
okay do you have more potential than
you're using
ask yourself right now just ask yourself
just meditate on this a second
do i have more potential than i'm using
dude you guys ask yourself that [ __ ]
every morning when you wake up man what
do you say to yourself in the morning
first thing i do in the morning i wake
up and say do i have more potential
thank you alex do i have more potential
than i'm using dude if i do
if it's even this much then i gotta get
the [ __ ] up and go get it
this is where god lives
dude this is the spiritual part of life
is the seeking of potential not the
seeking of sin
of serenity and happiness serenity and
happiness are [ __ ] selfish
commodities it's about me man
for me to seek my potential the next
level means i got to give up what i have
that's where god lives man
god's proud of grant cardone you know
what a bunch of humans don't like grant
god loves grant
yo you know what because god's like dude
that guy he will put it out there you
guys all praying you know what my prayer
is my prayer is not talking to god my
prayer is taking action i've been busted
broke beat up
i've been i've been to the point in my
life where i thought i thought less than
me than anyone thought of me how many
have been there
dude how do i get the right girl the
right family the right money the right
company the right employees i don't even
like me
i'm like what happened to me man what
happened
i had more money when i was eight than
when i was 25.
what the hell happened
i liked myself more when i was six years
old then i was 25 years old what
happened to me now if you look at me
today six years old and 57 dude i'm kind
of digging myself right now
i like who i am man i've spent the last
years just doing one thing dude working
on who i am number one most important
thing warren buffett says and i study a
lot of people okay this year i'll
probably spend this year between mentors
[Music]
which really my mentor is just the guys
to hook up he's hooking me up with other
players
20 mentors
i don't think i say the word
right uh books courses i'll go off for
three weeks and just do a course you
guys worry about a weekend
i can't get away for a weekend did i go
for three weeks and just do courses
i'll probably spend 400 grand this year
i'm worth it man
how am i not worth 400 grand look you
worried about 400 grand how are you
going to get 400 million
see you and i were brought up to worry
about what
[Music]
this what's in your pocket
[Music]
right
i mean i used to squeeze the quarter so
hard it fly
and scream
[Music]
look look everybody worries about this
right
[Music]
but whose money is this
somebody else's money man this ain't my
money i've already got a workout in
spent time with my kids did a project in
my office because we're doing some
construction there on my way to an event
and then we'll leave there go to another
event in another city
uh about uh 2000 miles away all in the
name of business that's what i say my
brothers my sisters my nephews and my
nieces
all business all weekend i don't think
people get out enough
the best things that have happened to me
in my life was when i left my room
my house
even the city that i lived in
and
i think we stay home too much guys get
out
ladies
leave your house get out
okay go out into the world
and see what's there even get get up
early to do it
again the best things that have happened
to me in my life happened outside my
house 29 years old
left the house
moved to houston i was terrified
i know somebody think oh man when ain't
scared of nothing i was so scared to
move
out of lake charles it was like one of
the most
terrifying things i've ever done in my
life
once i got there i was like that i don't
even know what i was scared about i
lived there for uh i don't know two uh
three four five
five years maybe
then i moved to la jolla california
didn't know one person there
had the life man i had the life in la
jolla i mean it was unbelievable
i actually went there with a person a
girlfriend me and a girlfriend moved
there i i
i got i moved there
she left about a year later maybe two
years later
i had the the single man's life
you know what i mean
in la jolla
i had made i was i was
loving life then i reached the point to
where i'm like uh i need to grow up now
i need
i want a wife and i want kids i'm on
grant street
look at that
uh i want a wife and kids
and i knew that that person was not in
ohio i'm talking to you about moving i'm
talking to you about getting outside and
talking to you about
leave man why have you been in one spot
so long
or maybe one spot you've been in for ten
years now you've moved once okay i left
i left la jolla moved to los angeles
california just so you guys know nobody
goes from what how you doing sir nobody
nobody moves from la jolla and goes to
l.a people go to from l.a to hawaii
have a great day huh
and uh
thanks a lot appreciate it
you guys are my book now you see how
would i meet that customer if i hadn't
left the house this morning the
hotel crazy dude
got to get out got to get out went to
l.a lived in la for
i don't know 12 years had it made in l.a
had this unbelievable house lionel
richie's i'm bragging
don't get me wrong i lived in lionel
richie's house
lionel wasn't there anymore so it's my
house now
i lived there and
and uh
all the parties were at my house it was
three quarters of an acre flat lot
in the hills above the sunset strip
tohini drive and oriole freaking
i mean spectacular place
we had our first two well we had our two
kids there in the house
all our friends have been there we got
married in that house i mean we were so
connected to that house it was
unbelievable elena and i when we first
saw the house it was four times my
budget
and i'm like we're buying that house and
you guys know how much i believe that
again how much i am against buying
houses
we fell so in love in that house in love
with each other in love with the house
in love with our kids there
in love with friends and parties and
memories and and decorations and antique
furniture we love that house and then it
reached a time where i'm like i think we
got to leave
what we love
we were so comfortable there
sure enough five years ago i got up and
moved to miami we've been in miami five
years now we travel all over the world
we're constantly moving my daddy told me
dr cara our local doctor he was the most
successful doctor in the in in uh we
knew both the most successful doctors dr
care and dr morin right
and dr care was at the house and they're
drinking martinis i'm like damn i'm
gonna do that too i'm gonna drink
martini and i'm gonna be james bond
right and dr carr came up to me and says
give me a dollar
i had a dollar too he's like give me
that dollar i'm like i ain't giving you
a dollar
my daddy said
never deny a man in power
never deny a man in power
okay never talk poorly about somebody in
power
push power to power
that's a good investment folks okay if
you're taking notes write this down push
power to power people that are doing
good things people that are making a
difference people that are out there
push power to power and ignore everyone
else
we don't help people that have nothing
i'm telling you right now i do not help
people that have nothing i have i help
people that have something
and want to make it more i'm not talking
about money right now
if somebody thinks they have nothing i'm
not helping that person if they think
they have nothing i can't help them if
you think you have something
and that you're not broke
i can help you if i take these people
right here
what do these people spend money on and
what do these people spend money on
remember rich is waiting to be poor or
it's waiting to get wealthy but it ain't
wealthy yet
what do the poor people y'all want to do
poor rich first let's do it listen to
poor people poor people spend money on
just give me give me anything what's
something
okay yeah yeah good a watch
i gotta have a techno marine that's what
i used to call it
i gotta have me some fake gucci
it's not even real gucci
it's gucci from the kana okay oh oh my
big goal in life is to buy a house this
guy's stuck in this too i'm gonna buy a
house one day
i'm gonna be a prisoner
the warden and
the prisoner
okay it's the castle
trips
trips right trips pleasure
okay uh vip vip this is my boy allen vip
in bottles bottle service
right cars
okay cars
belts
okay let me see my belt today
i got my belt dog
what did i spend on this belt
29 man 29 dollars
[ __ ] okay
watch
watch alert
my self-esteem is good today i left it
in the box
now what do these people buy what do
these people invest money on network
networking
these people are heavy heavy on who they
know man
okay
charity why charity because charity is
networking
who's at a charity event people that are
charitable
if you didn't spend any time in charity
events last last year i guarantee you've
got a money problem
this is connections okay these are
networking and connections the first
thing the rich people spend their money
on is connections wealthy people spend
their time with wealthy people we've
heard that over and over and over again
okay investments these people invest
money they don't spend money these are
spenders
over here right i'ma buy a watch it's
gonna be worth a lot of money one day
dude ain't gonna be worth any money to
who
oh my god man i'ma buy a paddock and i'm
gonna keep it for like three generations
and one day when you're dead man
okay
they invest in businesses they buy
franchises
uh we have people that buy a grant
cardone license
those are people that have a wealthy
mentality why they want to buy a grant
cardone license because they can use my
name my trademarks my products and go to
thailand and make money on my name
without me going to thailand
uh uh marketing these people these
people spend money on marketing
you know i'm convinced
that donald trump did not have a plane
before he was the president
because he needed to travel places i'm
convinced donald trump had a plane so he
could park it at laguardia and advertise
that he's a rich dude
people see his name he left it right
there at laguardia airport he didn't put
it at a private airport he put it at
laguardia so that every passenger that
leads new york out of laguardia would
see his big bird
what are you spending your money on in
2019 human beings are trapped in as
spiritual beings they're trapped this is
what i believe i belie i believe the
spiritual being is trapped in a body
okay i believe i'm a spiritual being not
a human being the spiritual being would
have tremendous potential unbelievable
potential it would be the light on the
candle not the candle the body would be
the candle
okay and and the spiritual being would
be the flame i i'm not i'm the flame
and and i want to see how hot can i burn
okay how far can i go how much light can
i bring the world how much positive
truth message can i bring this planet
how much more can i do and i think the
problem is people are settling out
with just enough
pay the bills take care of my family get
my little box
get my little house put my little
welcome mat on the front put the little
gate around the yard
we're all going to be happy i don't want
the box
i don't want one location i don't need
to welcome that i want to know the world
i want to travel the world i want to do
more i want to be in more places i want
to have friends in every country
i want to inspire people in every
language and i want other people to see
and they can do the same thing you know
and and maybe maybe maybe at the end of
all this
i just become everybody's uncle
that i never had if you're a business
owner you have to see the future if
you're an entrepreneur you have to look
forward to into the future what's going
to happen next if you're driving a car
it's responsible to look ahead everybody
agree
if you're skiing down a mountain you
might want to keep your attention out in
front of you if you're riding a
motorcycle
you might want to not pay attention to
right where you are but where you're
going
pay attention to the future what dreams
and goals do you have that are more
important than the money you have
invest money to hit your targets quit
telling yourselves lies about money
exchange money the only purpose of money
is to exchange money for time and
connections
the only reason you have money is to
exchange money for time
and people
you need people folks
[Music]
you need people man
you're going to grow your business with
people people that work for you and
people that you sell products to
be
so obsessed
with the idea of freedom and making a
difference that you will do anything
anything i'll go into debt i'll spend my
last dollar this is how you're going to
be successful folks i'll borrow money
from my mom i borrow from my dad i
borrow from from family members
i'll go raise money i'll go beg on a
street car i'll go sell t-shirts and
hats
failure after failure i'm obsessed so
much with my freedom that i'm willing to
talk to people even if i'm an introvert
okay i'm willing to go talk to old
people if i'm young i'm willing to go
talk to young people if i'm old i'm
willing if i'm out of work i'm willing
to go take a dumb sales job just to get
my feet back underneath me
become so obsessed
that everybody's like
what's wrong with you man
you change it you got to change your
friends
if your friends
you need to make these people your
friends
people that have time to get away people
that are working
people that are creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are
seeking to be better
i was i was hanging around people that
were destroying themselves every day
people that were criticizing others that
were successful
that were wasting time
beautiful rock
they weren't looking for anything
except how everybody else was wrong
how they had been wronged i know because
i was doing this
i spent all my time talking about how
the rich guy
that was had his kids in tennis classes
and golf classes
and they had a boat and they went skiing
how he was such a prick
and when reality sorry guys didn't mean
you to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality i should have been
looking at dude what did this guy do
to create
a situation
where he could pay for his kids
to learn
tennis
if they want to golf
and skiing
i was asking the wrong questions
i would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking
change the way you look at things
quit being so resentful and hateful my
business is kind of different i own a
hair salon
and i have
started a brand for myself and probably
went about it the wrong way i started it
um
doing booth rental instead of commission
and in the business i'm kind of maxed
out at making as much as i can make for
the size so i know i need to expand but
i also know that i have to be taken
serious as a woman and i feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing to do um
and i don't want to do it the wrong way
this time so i don't really know how to
be taken seriously i'm petite i have
blonde hair i always have crazy
fingernails or sometimes it's purple
sometimes it's blue yeah
so i guess the question would be where
where do i go from where i'm at get a
lot of attention i know i i think you
just got to get a lot of attention you
know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention like you have to get
people's attention you guys have to get
interesting
so again she doesn't like some of the
things i do i have to do that i believe
in my mind i have to do some of that to
capture attention whether that's true or
not true i don't know i don't know maybe
it's not true
you know i know this if somebody wants
to have a movie and it wants to be a
great movie at the theaters they got to
get a lot of attention and get somebody
to go to the movie you got to be willing
to get people not to like you
and what does that look like
just by promoting so much that you
irritate people like what does it mean
to get people not to like rush limbaugh
who's a pretty pretty divisive guy
uh says uh
you know the people that love him listen
to him two hours a day and the people
that hate him listen to him for four
hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so i'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked yeah everybody wants to be the the
popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible
oh i mean i do i'm i'm actually very
very good at my job i just don't know
how to um
take it take it to the next level i
guess maybe it's maybe i'm scared or i
haven't done what's your way what's your
facebook
right there nope the one underneath that
see i don't have a picture of you so i'm
gonna go is that is that you yes
or is that your kids um that well
there's a picture of me and then it's my
daughter
yeah so i mean
i don't want to see your daughter right
now
i have a hair therapy page um i don't
it's under hair therapy yeah i see hair
therapy i see it right here
so like right okay now we've got the
dogs
yeah but now oh yeah she's a
veterinarian
right
so like okay now i got hair okay that's
good before and after round like like
you guys gotta like like get clear on
what the message is right she needs a
you need a personal you need a business
page
right
the trick is you gotta get attention
elena just wrote a book called build an
empire okay she has to get attention for
the book which means leak out data about
the book not about anything else but
that book what is it what chapter what
audio what am i listening to why am i
listening to it what do i get out of it
like constant pushing into whatever you
do with hair therapy
okay
and and it see good good but but dinner
date but what do i do with the dinner
date yeah
see like you
this is where everybody's like when's
enough enough man when do you just enjoy
yourself
i don't know i'm gonna enjoy myself when
i'm in a position to just enjoy myself
you live on an economic planet
regardless of your race regardless of
where you came from regardless of your
religion you live on a planet that has
two things on it gravity i can't fly
and i'm reminded every day of gravity
right or wrong every day day i'm
reminded i'm reminded of it so much i
don't even know that it's not normal
that i shouldn't be able to jump seven
feet
right
and number two
money every day you were reminded this
is a financial planet okay i got a
little credit i don't have any cash on
me today none because i'm a real estate
guy
real estate guys are always broke
okay but i got me a little card
i can use this to open boxes
and i can use it to buy a box
right see how many were told all credit
credit cards are bad how many been told
debt is bad how many been trained that
oh oh all debt is bad debt i got about
500 million dollars worth of debt i got
to tell you i love it almost as much as
my wife and kids
i do love it man because it generates
income for me
now i'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it's because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job okay i've had all those
excuses
you have the wrong information the first
25 years of my life i use the
information that is being disseminated
by tv and mass media
save your money say yeah if you heard
that one
okay you were brought up on that one if
you were brought up poor middle class
say yay
no no you can't say it like that say it
like you're proud yes i must pour
say yay
no no well you brought up poorer middle
class
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you something it's gonna
take you forever if you don't get your
freaking enthusiasm right look if you're
poor admit it
but damn i'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be
if you're in the middle by the way if
you're middle class and you got three
meals a day you got a car out there you
can make the payments on you got a
little education that you think is worth
something and it's not okay
and you got a good mom and a good dad
and you're brought up in a good family
good for you but dude i don't pay the
bills you ever ask yourself dude when
are you going to make it are you do you
ever suffer from this idea that you
could do more than you're doing
and no matter how much people around you
love you or
oh you're doing great patching in the
back you're doing phenomenal amazing
i've been told my whole life i was doing
amazing i remember being was 29 years
old i was the leading sales person where
i where i worked
i mean i wasn't the best person i was
the best sales person by like three or
four people
breaking records doing stuff that had
never been done
everybody's telling me how great i was
and i was like i know i can do more
i don't know if that's suffering
suffering some kind of like
mental disease some kind of
never satisfied with i've heard all
these people talk about
i remember the guy said hey your
disappointments are
your disappointments in life are equal
to your expectations
suggesting that you not have
expectations
if you lower your expectations then you
won't have disappointments i gotta tell
you man i i mean i can't even make sense
of that i'm like i have to have
expectations of myself i know i can do
better i know i can do more
so
if
me having big expectations for myself
and i'm going to be disappointed from
time to time that's the way it's got to
be the one other thing that i would tell
my 20 year old self look i own seven
businesses
and i would not tell you
i would not tell the 20 year old grant
to go get six six businesses
i would tell him
to learn everything he can about real
estate
everything
real estate is the business that's
allowed me to go on these magnificent
trips that i'm taking my family on i've
been in business for myself for 30 years
okay six businesses do not
six businesses combined do not allow me
to go on these trips it is the real
estate by and of itself
that's allowed me to take my
wife and kids
employees partners friends on these
magnificent trips when you're hating on
somebody in your same space right or
they're hating on you remember this you
keep focused on creating massive massive
success
okay because
when you get up to the top of the food
chain whatever the food chain is in your
space whether it's financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters
or or maybe you're doing a real business
you're not doing it you're not an
influencer and you're not a podcaster
you're like why all these guys spending
all this time doing podcasts i got a
business to grow i got employees
maybe you're doing that
so
what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
i'm doing this for you i don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this i'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it you will get up the food
chain you will become a super successful
person but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time
to worry about these other people in
your space flowing power man
loving them
send them love send them customers send
them deals but don't be surprised
when they don't send it back
because they're not
no book
tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy
scarcity but watch how they act when you
get up there man watch it man it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be like cardone
told me
while i was eating snow
the dude told me
that they were gonna hate on me i had i
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude i want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against
okay because there's a way for you to
prevent some of this
some of these people hating on you i
said dude i don't i'm not going to try
to prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb i got enough insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure that these
haters and criticizers and little
thinkers don't bother you is don't be
them number one number two
keep following love and power baby
number three number three number three
get to the top
get to the top of the food chain where
everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up
or wish they didn't do what they did we
saw the fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and showing off and bragging
and running your mouth
you can still get cracked
you got
you know huh
yeah too many days off man too many days
off you got to pay the price every day
folks otherwise you lose
period
you will get beat
you're going to get beat in the
marketplace if you don't train every day
i'm wearing my cardone university
t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated to do the right thing if
you don't train every day if you don't
require training every day if it's not
mandatory every day you will not get the
cash flow
you will get just enough money to pay
the bills and by the way everybody's got
that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree so don't be bragging about your
bicycles and your two bmws and your
country club that you paid for and the
roof over your head and you paid your
utilities and your gas and don't tell me
that all somebody else has got it worse
than you of course somebody else has got
it worse than you i hear this all the
time from people
okay somebody gets whacked they have a
bad situation and they're like but i'm
grateful
well you mean you're grateful man you're
filing bankruptcy i know but i still got
my health
but you don't have your financial health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt you
should have prepared for it don't make
sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes quit making sense of the
failures i want to talk to you about the
cash
flow i'm talking about the cash flow not
the snow i'm talking about getting that
third flow
you work your wife works
yeah y'all cracking some freaking smack
daddy money you getting some long green
you made your first million dollars last
year that's right between the two of you
after you paid your taxes you end up
with four or five maybe 600
if you know how to play the game
but what you don't have is number three
your cash don't work you got scared once
you put away your first milli you and
the wife are like oh no what do we do
now you called your uncle not me not
uncle g you called your other uncle the
confused uncle he said pay the house off
you called your financial advisor start
investing in 401ks in the iras
and then you saw something i said about
cash
it's trash
a home is dumb equity what are you doing
folks get that third flow
it's like a good snowstorm baby you need
that third flow when you can't work
you can't crank
you can't create
the third flow of income is the one you
buy you take your debt money cash is
trash take that dead money and get it
invested in hard assets
and only make a decision to invest in
those things that pay you cash flow
you invest cash you get back cash
every
single
month i want to tell you a story
when i grew up
my first failure
happened
in a baseball park
[Music]
i had a dream
that i would be a professional baseball
player
and i lost that dream
to drugs
you guys don't give up on your dreams
i'm not here to jack you up i'm not here
to get you excited i'm here to be an
example
i'm not your friend
i'm your uncle g
two minutes with me every day two
minutes
i go to the gym and work out every day
six days in a week
all i ask you to do
turn on your computer
spend two minutes
with me
every day
stop the bull
stop the netflix
give me two minutes
give me two minutes
you give me two minutes every day i'll
change your life forever
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there